devant comme ça mario brothers à la
piqûre pour les abeilles
depuis deux ans il fait partie de la
dizaine d'apprentis apiculteurs qui
s'occupe des ruches installées sur le
toit de l'accueil bonneau
une activité qui l'a transformé bagnols
différence
le sens plus responsable plus autonome
à prévoir les gens afin que
des bateaux mouches par la botte de
doudou shdm inspecté une ruche vérifier
l'état de santé d'une colonie et sa
reine
les apiculteurs en herbe peuvent compter
sur l'entreprise alvéoles pour apprendre
leur métier
l'un d'entre eux y a même décroché un
emploi si les cellules que vont ils vont
utiliser pour faire la reine il ya un
échange qui fait avec l'intermédiaire
des abeilles mais qui incroyablement
humain comme j'ai dit je me suis fait
des amis c'est des personnes que j'ai
appris à connaître que c'est un plaisir
de retrouver à chaque semaine dans le
cadre du projet plus de 70 ruches seront
installées à différents endroits dans le
grand montréal
l'objectif de l'accueil bonneau et de
produire 1400 kg de miel cette saison ce
qui permettra de vendre 5000 peau comme
ceux ci qui vont entre autres se
retrouver sur les tablettes des
épiceries métro avec leurs rôles
d'insectes pollinisateurs les abeilles
contribuent à nourrir la planète mais
elles sont en mauvaise posture des taux
de mortalité deux à trois fois plus
élevé que la normale sont présentement
observée en europe et en amérique du
nord
l'épée style évidemment qui sont au
coeur de la problématique mais aussi à
tout ce qui est des facteurs
environnementaux donc les changements
climatiques la manipulation des abeilles
la malnutrition
on a aussi la présence de parasites des
champignons des bactéries comme ça je
peux le passé que lutter grâce à son
petit salaire d'apprenti apiculteurs
mario pour aller rendre visite à sa
famille en gaspésie cet été ce qu'il ne
faisait pas auparavant
depuis que la mienne il m'a promis
ces fumées safia c'est merveilleux ici
olivier bastin radio canada montréal